so tell me have you been how are you
feeling
I mean it's O'Conner every room with you
and want to switch rooms Connor because
he was afraid that you might lose I
don't know I just wait this is like 100%
serious yeah okay that actually makes me
feel extremely uncomfortable it's not so
I wanna get to the bottom of it but like
when I hear things that the guys are
maybe more scared around you or they
feel threatened or that you're verbally
abusive I'm gonna ask you about it this
is completely fabricated and it's not
real
nor is it right hello was I on last feel
Becca
let it out do I feel like I usually take
like five minutes to myself you're gonna
go away do you mind yeah no I'll come
grab you huh yeah you're gonna go
downstairs with the guys Jack I'm sorry
just doing that so uh Connor the word is
that you're scared to room with me
because I'm very aggressive and verbally
abusive where did that come from I was
just told this letter go-gurt I don't
know what you're talking about right now
but whatever you said you're up there
put her in a head state where it just
that's the whole night